les conférences de Lucas Zidane sur le
poids de son nom de famille c'est vrai
que là il faut savoir que les quatre
enfants de Zidane ils font tous du foot
alors Lucas il est gardien de but c'est
ça il est à elle barre en D2 espagnol
et il a dit certaines personnes pensent
que c'est quelque chose de positif mais
ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est pas le cas
j'aimerais que tout le monde du football
que tout le monde du football me voit
comme Lucas qu'il juge des matchs que je
fais qui ne cherchent pas plus loin et
qui ne me compare pas
si son père était resté ouvrier ou je ne
sais quoi il serait évidemment pas
footballeur alors maintenant il a la
chance d'être footballeur il y a une
chance sur un million qui s'occupe
juste compliqué d'être le fils d'une
célébrité
plus entendre aussi c'est compliqué si
ça peut être compliqué
en fait ça peut être compliqué à Madame
c'est qui à partir du moment où il est
footballeur parce que évidemment dans le
compare à son père et tout ça mais il a
une chance énorme d'être arrivé là parce
que son père était
son père n'était rien il est par son
talent immense il est devenu quelque
chose il en profite et moi je le
condamne pas tant mieux mais j'en ai
assez de cette petite musique pauvre ils
ont de la chance
il dit que c'est difficile d'entendre je
pense je pense que les critiques ça va
être du genre tu es au foot parce que tu
t'appelles Zidane alors
des deux aujourd'hui c'est pas un club
qui est là pour faire gagner la coupe à
la saucisse du dimanche en des deux il y
a des histoires d'argent il mettrait pas
une pompe à vélo gardien en deuxième
division parce qu'il s'appelle Zidane
ils veulent pas prendre un but quand il
joue ses cadeaux
c'est tout un ensemble pour qu'on
favoriser mais non mais je parle pas le
foot alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et
pourquoi j'ai pas question
je pense décoder le Daniel couramment ce
qui veut dire c'est que elle dit pas
qu'il a pas de talent elle dit que il a
pas de raison de se plaindre de ce
président
mais il a été évidemment favorisé par
contre
il y en a un autre il y en a un autre
qui qui se plaint mais qui explique
c'est parfois compliqué moi je le
comprends très bien
Delon
soyez un petit peu
urbain
s
je pense que de là d'où je viens je
souffre un peu du syndrome de
l'imposteur de temps en temps parce que
il y a un père voilà clairement une
légende et un nom déjà c'est ça et de la
comparaison permanente entre tout le
temps j'aime jouer j'adore jouer c'est
quand même un le plus beau métier du
monde j'essaye pas de remplacer pour le
coup mon père ou qui que ce soit dans le
métier mais j'aimerais juste y faire ma
place et
vous êtes encore là
c'est pas possible d'entendre ça
sincèrement est-ce que franchement
Benjamin Benjamin les yeux dans les yeux
parce que vous voulez défendez est-ce
que c'est
un ami à moi oui mais vous mais déjà et
je vais vous dire c'est très compliqué
mais oui justement moi j'ai une chance
et que moi excusez-moi et je vais pas
vexer mon père mais mon père était pas
une énorme star c'était un acteur
moi j'ai des grands-parents illustres
mais j'ai pas eu le poids elle
s'appelait de long vous pouvez monter
des cendres c'est compliqué moi je me
mets à sa place
c'est compliqué après il y a ceux qui le
vivent très bien vous avez un mec comme
Cassel qui est un gigantesque acteur qui
a presque presque fait oublier son
propre père qui avait une carrière plus
grande que son père mais Cassel
excusez-moi c'est un peu comme Castaldi
qui a 7 c'était pas non plus une énorme
star donc c'est non quand vous avez un
père qui est pas parce que là on parle
d'un mythe de lancer c'est les monstres
vous voyez donc ouais et d'ailleurs vous
voyez bien ceux qui sont vraiment des
les les enfants de monstre c'est très
compliqué pour eux c'est général après
ce qui ont une lignée c'est plus facile
il se lance dans une carrière d'acteurs
c'est-à-dire que là il doit assumer le
fait potentiellement d'être comparé
c'est normal se lance dans la carrière
d'acteur c'est parce que son père était
oui parce que je trouve pas logique
c'est qu'après il se plaint pas
un autre exemple c'est ma mère ma mère
c'est la fille de Simone Signoret qui
était une immense actrice qui avait un
Oscar elle a jamais fait la carrière
qu'elle aurait voulu avoir parce qu'on a
passé son temps à lui dire et elle dit
aujourd'hui si j'avais si ce n'est à
refaire j'aurais certainement dû faire
un autre métier parce que c'était
totalement impossible quand on a une
mère aussi célèbre de faire le même
métier voilà et c'est normal de faire du
cinéma quand tu étais baigné depuis ton
enfance dans un monde de cinéma comme tu
fais paysans contre père était paysan
parce que voilà il a raison là-dedans tu
sais faire quoi quoi et moi je dis oui
que c'est dur évidemment d'être fils de
et tu en as fait exactement c'est que
toute ta vie il y a des gens comme toi
qui diront il est là parce qu'il
s'appelle comme ça tu l'as dit ici il
t'a dit ça tu as dit il il a pas de
raison de se plaindre s'il était pas
fait de Zidane il serait jamais gardé le
but mais tu l'as dit de se plaindre s'il
te plaignent parce que si ça plaît pas
Zidane il serait certainement pas là où
il est et voilà c'est la vérité
mes parents je serai jamais entré chez
Drucker hein bah bien sûr voilà
j'ai eu la chance qu'on me mette le pied
d’étrier oui mais tu as vu ça
là non mais il y a sûrement des tas de
gens qui ont autant talent que moi mais
qui est pas la chance de pouvoir rentrer
j'ai été aidé j'ai été aidé vous avez
des questions
on est tous les pistolet de quelqu'un un
jour dans tous les métiers
vous connaissez ça charcuterie ça c'est
vrai
les gens peuvent avoir du talent même en
ayant un nom de famille
des trucs comme ça parce que moi je
reçois des personnalités tous les jours
qui viennent me dire en effet ça et en
rentrant ils me disent bon j'ai dit ça
mais parce que en vrai je le pense pas
et ça me rend fou
c'est choquant ce que vous avez dit
quand même hein vous avez dit on est
tous le pistonné de bien sûr ça marche
on a tous été aidé à un moment donné
dans sa vie bien sûr que si j'ai dans
nos milieux privilégiés il y a plein de
jeunes qui sont pas pistolet du tout et
ça c'est l'ascenseur social heureusement
que ça existe et qui arrive justement à
faire des carrières sans être baigné
dans un milieu qui n'est favorise et à
s'élever et eux ils ont beaucoup plus de
mérites que nous tous vous voyez ce que
je veux dire je trouve c'est chaud
dans la vie on est tous réponses
rien du tout et qui arrive à se hisser
au sol majorité si tu veux dire alors on
va demander comment elle a décroché son
rôle dans Batman non mais blague à part
il y a des gens qui sont des fils de
comment Angelina Jolie qui a pris un
pseudonyme justement
un bon acteur c'est pas une star
mondiale et c'est pas un c'est pas une
icône
c'est pas une icône extrêmement connue
John Voight aux États-Unis je suis
désolé
mais les gens qui ont des extrêmement
connu bénéficie sont ultra privilégiés
depuis l'enfance ils ont un réseau ils
baignent tous les copains des parents
c'est les directeurs de casting c'est
les producteurs des réalisateurs etc
même sans rien faire il bénéficie d'un
réseau absolument énorme en plus ils
sont coachés par leur parent qui ont
déjà vécu mais oui mais c'est des
conseils que moi je n'ai jamais été
pistonné dans ce métier j'ai tout fait à
partir de
zérotiste pour moi elle a beaucoup de
talents ça boite la fille de du coup
il a autant de talent plus que son père
il se plaint pas voilà c'est ça
je me sens mal parce que mon père il
était tellement connu gagné tellement
d'argent que je sais pas si moi je vais
réussir en gagner autant mais c'est bon
en fait
j'ai déjà une chance extraordinaire
si je serai aussi bon que mon père c'est
ce qu'il est merci déjà d'être à la
place à laquelle je suis
pas là
il a pas appelé TF1 pour dire j'ai un
truc je me plains voilà on lui pose
naturellement les questions puisque
c'est le long est-ce que c'est pour vous
c'est pas parfait et
on n'arrête pas
de souci
en France il y a un hypotisme il y a un
vrai népotisme en France quand on
regarde les dossiers
on privilégie toujours les enfants
d'avoir connu et cetera dans les médias
on le voit partout dans dans le
journalisme dans dans la dans les actes
chez les acteurs chez les voilà c'est
tout c'est comme ça c'est non mais
effectivement il y a évidemment un
milieu qui est privilégié où il y a un
coup de pouce mais nous en tant que
parents quand on peut aider un enfant
notre enfant tout le tous les parents
qui sont là on aide nos enfants bien sûr
on peut le faire effectivement quand il
s'appelle Alain Delon bah on met de son
enfant voilà donc on lui ouvre des
portes et c'est normal en tant que
favoriser donc il y a des milieux
favorisés
contre ça tu découvres la vie
montre-moi
une élite et ça marche
supportable il n'est pas en train de se
plaindre
une question mais c'est comme si vous
mettiez en fait une espèce d'échelle de
valeur de souffrance chez les gens qui
ont de l'argent et chez les gens qui
sont privilégiés et les autres si c'est
une souffrance pour lui on peut le
comprendre il a le droit de l'exprimer
il faudrait qu'il ferme sa bouche on va
descendre la mentalité française
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs et le changement non vous
parlez de votre maman qui s'appelle
Catherine Allégret bon bah elle avait
pas le même nom que Signoret bah c'est
voilà donc le changement de nom il fait
rien la fille de Romy Schneider qui a un
nom différent elle en a souffert aussi
tout perdu
Johnny Hallyday et que c'est un très bon
musicien David Hallyday on sait que tu
vas incroyable bah oui il était
peut-être en souffrance à certains
moments
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est pas bien c'est pas bien parce que
c'est faux
quand je pense à tout ce que je fais
pour vous
dès qu'il a un problème
qui sont fermés à tout le monde sauf aux
gens qui sont un peu connus qui dit
qu'il appelle
[Applaudissements]
des rendez-vous inaccessibles c'est
encore mimi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]